MSNBC goes wild for mayor Pete Stephen
Colbert spills the beans on political
comedy and President Trump gets the
Royal Treatment I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show well Trump in
Britain always is going to bring the
laughs so we have a lot to laugh about
today mostly the president doing pretty
good job over in Britain and the Brits
making clear that their brand of comedy
has sunk a bit since Monty Python we'll
get to all of that in just a second
first we're never gonna agree on
everything but I think we can all agree
that we can use more sleep I am one of
those humans getting a great night's
sleep is easier and more affordable than
you think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you need to
change your sheets that's why you should
check out bull and branch you think your
sheets don't matter you think I've got a
great mattress I got a great bed frame
everything no the sheets need to be good
everything bull and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time you buy directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand bucks in the store
bolon brand sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks everyone who tries Boleyn
brand sheets loves them shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund I tell you're gonna want to send
them back because they're awesome
they're so good that when my wife and I
got ball and branch eats we threw out
all of our others because they ruin
other sheets for you that's how good
they are there's no risk and no reason
not to give them a try to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
bolo and branch com promo code been when
a bull and branch calm today for 50
bucks off your first set of sheets
that's Bo LL and branch calm promo code
been bull and branch calm promo code Ben
go check it out right now okay we begin
today with more media heroism so over
the past 48 hours really over the past
week we've seen an enormous amount of
journalism I mean true journalism in so
we saw The Daily Beast go after a Rando
who posted a video of Nancy Pelosi
slurring her words because it was deeply
important for us to find out that he was
an african-american trump supporter who
had an itinerant work history and had a
criminal conviction very very important
and then today yet BuzzFeed go after a
guy for the grand crime of properly
handling a racist according to a scale
writing over the Daily wire a man
working the front desk at a Holiday Inn
Express in Austin Texas became an
Internet hero on Monday due to the way
he call
responded to a woman who had called him
an effing n-word earlier on the phone
the man filmed himself telling the woman
he wouldn't let her stay at the hotel
and that it's above me now the woman
apologizes for the slurs she said she
said she had a bad day a family member
had recently died the hotel clerk didn't
give in he said it was hurtful for him
to hear what she said and directed her
to the Best Western Hotel next door the
guy happens to be both black and gay he
quickly became a meme on Sunday night
and into Monday good news
BuzzFeed then decided to drag up his old
tweets I kid you not so this guy
apparently properly handled a racist who
called him an effing n-word on the phone
and then everybody decided it was
important to resurface everything he had
ever written on Twitter and thus to ruin
his life
BuzzFeed News wrote about his video soon
after internet sleuths
as BuzzFeed News called them and this is
what we're calling people or jackasses
now people who decide that whenever
anybody jumps into the public eye we
have to go back and look up anything
they have ever said you know that human
beings are not shaded either they are
entirely good in heroic or they are
entirely bad and evil and if they've
done a bad or evil thing or even a thing
that has just crossed the politically
correct lines drawn by our society if
they do those things then we have to
cast them out among the Leopards the
lepers BuzzFeed news wrote that internet
sleuths dug through the man's old tweets
and found his past comments about
transgender individuals blue checked
Twitter users then amplified his past
tweets many of which simply state his
opinion that he doesn't agree with
transgenderism and pointing out that men
can't get pregnant and women can't
fertilize an egg which is basic biology
other tweets were responding to members
of the trans community criticizing his
tweets it doesn't matter the guy is gay
and black not intersectional enough my
friends he happens to be a biological
man who believes that biological males
exist
BuzzFeed took its original story Louden
the guy and then updated it to include
the man's past tweets and join in on the
shaming the man initially responded
repeating what he had said on Twitter
that he was not against transgender
individuals but he's not with it meaning
the phenomenon of society approving of
transgenderism as something but a mental
disorder presumably he said they're mad
lol I said what I said people are so
sensitive I'm gay and I know people will
not agree with me being gay I just don't
and we'll never get trans period that
didn't stop the social justice mob from
coming after him so this is the way
thing
work now a guy does something that the
left Cheers and then even that guy gets
destroyed because he once posted a tweet
that some people on the social justice
warrior left do not like this is the
world in which we now love and our
mainstream media outlets pushing this
BuzzFeed news is a mainstream outlet it
is a highly highly trafficked outlet
with production deals in place from
major companies for tens of millions of
dollars so newsy so incredibly newsy
BuzzFeed of course just last week went
after me with the suggestion that a guy
who tried to swastika a synagogue had
been inspired by my writing which you'd
have to be insane to believe I'm an
Orthodox Jew who is the lead antagonist
of the alt-right
but BuzzFeed news doing yeoman's work
The Daily Beast doing yeoman's work
resurfacing all of the criminal history
of a man who made a video about Nancy
Pelosi that made her seem slightly drunk
man I'm so glad our journalists are on
the beat I can't understand why
Americans don't take our media so
seriously anymore I just I don't
understand it I mean when they are
engaged in such journalism in on a
regular basis
why wouldn't we take them seriously
these are these are the people leading
the honest truth to power people
absolute truth to power and it spreads
over into obviously presidential
politics so good Matthews I don't know
say it's doing area Peabody jej mayor
pink South Bend Indiana and yeah there's
a stair no much back up in the morning
some of the show come on in is it
where's Indiana everybody says I don't
know
I said well seems like a state yeah like
the Pacers they playing Indiana right
he said Reggie Miller it's a good player
Rik Smits don't know much about him
beyond that ah well he decides that he's
gonna have on Pete Buddha judge I will
point out here but these town halls that
have been run on Fox News have been run
with their objective news anchors
there'll be people like Martha McCallum
or people like prepare the the town
halls on MSNBC I run by Chris Matthews
an ardent Democrat like to push
Democrats it's how do you possibly can
yep in the morning coming on this show
and push Democrats put him on my little
scooter push him out here so here he is
praising people to judge he opens up by
talking about Peabody judge being the
most important candidate since Jesus
Christ first arrived in
Bethlehem I mean this guy is just mayor
Pete is a hero to millions he's a saint
listen to this intro from Chris Matthews
honestly this is not shocking Chris
Matthews and if you remember this but
back in 2008 he talked about a guy take
up his leg sitting here watching Barack
Obama sitting at her suddenly my leg is
tingling I thought my having a heart
attack now wasn't a heart attack it was
sexual attraction Chris Matthews talk
about mayor Pete bootie judge go not
since Barack Obama was a candidate has
someone ignited so much buzz so fast
he's 37 years old I graduated Harvard a
Rhodes Scholar a Naval Reserve Officer
was deployed to Afghanistan and the
mayor of a small city in Indiana
population 100,000 feet Buddha judge he
says his eight years leading South Bend
Indiana gives him more experience to be
President
than Donald Trump head he gave me a tour
of his hometown which a decade ago was
cited as one of America's ten dying
cities the same year Buddha judge was
elected mayor and then he proceeds to go
into this hagiographic description of
South Bend how everything is all better
the crime rates in South Bend still
sucked by the South Penn has not been
healed as a city you know Buddha jej is
a controversial mayor to say the least
he is not this this kind of wonder
wunderkind mayor who has healed the city
and made all the problems go away there
a lot of minority folks in the city who
are very angry people who to judge they
say that he basically was bulldozing
minority-owned housing for some of his
public-private projects in any case that
opener that he's the most buzzed-about
candidate since Barack Obama in 2008
yeah there's this guy who ran for
president I know if you remember his
name
2015 or so comes down an escalator and
proceeds to own every piece of media
coverage ever like media coverage going
back all the way to the time of the
Romans this guy was so buzzed about that
he became president on the basis of
basically being him you may recall him
because he's currently President of the
United States we're gonna talk about
candidates who have drawn buzz mayor
Pete don't rank in like the top five
mayor Pete has driven enough buzz to get
him to about 6 percent in the latest
polls presidential II bet that's where
he is okay there is a new CNN poll out
today Pete Budaj edge is at five
percent five percent does that sound
like somebody who's received just the
most buzz since Barack Obama dozen to me
sounds like somebody who's got a lot of
people in sort of the left-liberal
white enclaves of the media buzzing but
outside those on cliff does anybody give
a crap about people to judge really not
so much he's kind of like beta O'Rourke
by the way he is tied with beta O'Rourke
in the polls right now but apparently
according to Chris Matthews so much
generalize men just generally swing all
over people judge over here talking
about people who to judge me most
buzzed-about candidate I trust our
journalistic class man are they good at
their jobs and then my favorite part of
this particular interview with Peabody
judge is Matthews basically trying to
steer Peabody judge where he wants him
to go it really is incredible it's like
me trying to teach my five-year-old how
to ride a bicycle they sort of point her
front wheel and you give her a little
push and then she sort of falls over
that was this interview he booed a judge
fell over a lot and Chris Matt and then
when my daughter falls over on her bike
and I say good job honey let's try it
again
that was this interview basically Chris
Matthews gets Pete Buddha judge around
the place okay we gotta push it down
this hill a little bit if you fall over
but pick you right up they'll paint
we'll pick you right up brush off your
boo-boos and then we'll talk some more
about why you so great so here is Chris
Matthews talking to people judge about
slavery reparations which for the record
was not on the table for Democrats until
five minutes ago everybody in the
Democratic Party feels the necessity now
to talk about slavery reparations now
check my math slavery ended in the
United States in 1865 the current year
if I am not mistaken his 2019 that means
that a hundred and fifty four years
later we are talking about slavery
reparations to people who are the
great-great-great great-great
grandchildren of slaves for the most
part and from people who were never
involved in slavery the vast majority of
white people in America were never
involved in slavery many of them are
descended from people who died to end
slavery nonetheless this has become kind
of the rote part of the Democratic stump
speech in 2020s that slavery reparations
ought to be on the table all because
everybody in the left has also decided
doneghy see coaches great intellect the
wildly overrated writer from the
Atlantic who's whose expertise in purple
prose my goodness
that guy's writing is overwrought he
thinks he's James Baldwin he's like
James Baldwin if somebody took an entire
bucket of fuchsia paint and poured it on
him I mean is it his writing is just
dripping with overwrought annoying
purple silliness and everybody on the
Left has embraced it because of course
this is how they show their work so
here's Chris Matthews urging people to
judge to show that he's well Buddha
judged by the way needs this because
Buddha judge has approximately zero
percent of the black vote right now
because it turns out that black voters
are not super into a 37 year old mayor
from South Bend Indiana who has no
particular connection with the black
community so now we're going to just try
to go full pander here's Chris Matt
let's talk about slavery reparations
people just what do you think slavery is
good or the bad let's do this thing what
would be the form of represent on going
enduring value to african-americans in
this country not just money up front but
a change in their opportunity well
that's what how do you do it yeah that's
what the Commission ought to work out
but there's no way you can do without
putting dollar resources behind it now
the right can't wait to caricature this
as a check in the mail that they say
would be unfair but we did it with
japanese-americans that's right and
there can be ways of doing this that are
fair or at least bring us to a more just
reality than the one we're living in
right is okay that sounds like not an
answer that sounds like I love Chris
Matthews saying it right that's a good
idea Commission people would talk about
it and then that and the Republicans are
main I great I great putti judge yes so
much journalism I love people who judge
his response to all of that you know
that we did this with you with
japanese-americans yes they had just
been freed from internment unjust
internment during World War two so the
people who had been wrongly imprisoned
were paid money just like today people
who are wrongly imprisoned are usually
given my massive legal settlements the
japanese-americans were not talking
about their victimization at the hands
of other people 154 years beforehand or
how that would get done don't worry
there's more chris matthews coming up so
if you love my chris matthews
impersonation man you're gonna get
plenty of it coming up in a second first
fine
new job is a lot of work what if you had
your own personal recruiter to help you
find a better job now zip recruiters
technology can do just that for you just
download the zip recruiter job search
app let it know what kind of jobs you're
interested in its technology starts
doing the work the zipper career app
finds jobs you like and put your profile
in front of employers who may be looking
for somebody like you if an employer
likes your profile zip recruiter lets
you know so if you're interested in the
job you can apply no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated job
search app my listeners should download
the free zip recruiter job search app
today and let the power of technology
work for you don't wait the sooner you
download the free zip recruiter job
search app the sooner it can help you
find a better job so zip occur is not
just for employers looking for employees
it is for prospective employees looking
for a solid employer so if you're
looking to work it for example daily
wire and you want to be notified when a
job comes free zip recruiter is the
place to do it go ahead over to zip
recruiter job search app go download it
right now it will help you find a better
job this is what zip recruiters here to
do connect good employees with good
employers and make everybody's life
better yay free markets zip recruiter
job search app go download it right this
very instant okay so Chris Matthews
continues on his tour of Peabody jgies
mind it's great so he continues along
this way gets up in the morning comes
out it's show and he talks about
impeachment
won't you impeach impeach do it Peabody
judge doesn't matter the Buddha judge
isn't in Congress doesn't matter that
he's not gonna be President a separate
impeachment go near you down if you were
voting in Congress right now in a piece
would you vote to impeach okay good
question is looking for an answer
they definitely going to get right there
now that's journalism journalism Inc all
up in here I mean unbelievable
and then Chris Matthews finally asks
Peabody judge about his take regarding
Vladimir Putin he says that he says that
he wants Buddha judge to respond to how
he what he would say to Putin the first
time what did you say to him I have
these fantasies they put a judge that
the first time you meet Vladimir Putin
you'd rip his face off and shove it up
his ass that's my fantasy ruining my
fantasies come true for real
Peabody judge what would you say Chris
Matthews let me say C Gao
the United States what would you say to
Vladimir Putin the first time you met
don't we'll get to meet him well don't
mess with our elections thank you thank
you oh my God look at the toughness on
him he said don't mess about elections
and then Vladimir Putin was laughing his
face and rip his leg off and beat him to
death of it how is that even a question
what would you say I have a fantasy why
would you say booty judge well how about
like what would your policy be to
counter Russian aggression like that's a
question but I love the fanfic that is
happening here from Chris Matthews and
the left media to these Democratic
candidates what would you say would it
be the most would you send most brutal
thing would you say a cutting remark a
witty cutting aaron sorkin remark people
to judge we do and people just yeah I
would say stop messing with our
elections you think thank you oh my god
i tingling in the leg in the head
everywhere tingling everywhere why don't
people trust our media why we move
questions being asked like that what now
listen I know that there are a lot of
people on the left right now listening
and they're going well listen Fox News
did the same thing with President Trump
and it is true there are hosts on Fox
News who did exactly the same thing with
President Trump and you know what I did
I made fun of them go back and listen to
the show back in 2016 I am not very much
in favor of journalists asking questions
to politicians that are simply there for
purposes of kiss-ass or these sort of
leading them around on leash here's the
answer I want you to give to me and then
if I get that answer I will show you how
pleased I am I don't like it when it's
right or when it's left this is why a
lot of people have criticized the media
for being harsh on Trump I've never
really criticized the media for being
harsh to Trump I've criticized the media
for being unfair to Trump and there's
been a lot of that mischaracterization
of President Trump drawing conclusions
where conclusions do not need to be
drawn attempting to push a Russian
collusion hoax that was in fact a hoax
there was no collusion exaggerating
evidence that wasn't there suggesting
that the big the big scandal was just
around the corner right all of that
stuff was a bunch of crap and I ripped
the media for that but when it came to
their covering how he handles Trump
Hotel or they're covering the Trump
Tower meeting or they're covering the
stuff that President Trump has said at
odd times and he said bad things I've
never ripped the me
for that in fact I've been one of the
few commentators on the right who has
said that when President Trump says fake
news i I do not like the label unless it
is being applied to legitimately fake
news when he applies it to just stuff he
doesn't like that is not fake news
that's just stuff that Trump doesn't
like I'm also one of the few people on
the right who has said that when Trump
uses the enemy of the people routine I
don't like that either Chris Matthews
isn't an enemy of the people he may be
an enemy of intelligence but he is not
an enemy of the people he may be an
enemy of hairspray but he is not an
enemy of the people
right he just he disagrees with me okay
he disagrees with you that's that's fine
but when people look at the media and
they see folks like Chris Matthews run
out there as journalists it begins to
annoy them and it's not just our
journalist class it is also our comedian
class one of the things that is highly
irritating to so many people on the
right that there are certain groups of
professions where you assume that a
certain level of baseline honesty and
that honesty is supposed to extend to
both sides of the aisle and I think one
of the reasons that people like this
show is because everybody knows I'm
conservative and very open about that
but I'm gonna give you my honest take on
what's happening in politics this is why
when President Trump does something good
I will praise it when he does something
bad I will rip it because you're getting
my honest take on this stuff well people
sort of expect the same thing from their
comedians except the comedians don't
come out and state their politics openly
instead they pretend that they're just
there for the comedy we're just here
because we are comic relief we're just
here to be the jesters to the the high
and the mighty to mock them in the way
that the the jester mcc's King leader
and we're just gonna walk around and
we're going to comment on the action
that's what comedians were there to do
and so when people on the right look at
comedians and it turns out that a bunch
of leftist acts you basically are Chris
Matthews with a couple of badly written
punchlines people start to get angry
it's no wonder that the write is angry
at late-night TV because this is what
late-night TV has become Stephen Colbert
has a long interview in The New York
Times Magazine
which is the most boring magazine in the
world apparently I mean it's like it's
like nuns life
the New York Times magazine in terms of
its in any case yes that was an airplane
reference in any case the the interview
with Stephen Colbert in the New York
Times is pretty telling because he does
state exactly where he is and this is
why everyone on the right has turned off
Stephen Colbert it's also why the left
which has decided to
lit asides everything has basically made
Stephen Colbert at the champion of late
night so Colbert is not funny there was
a time when he was on The Daily Show
when he was funny because his mandate
was to go make fun of pretty much
everybody and so as a correspondent on
The Daily Show I vividly recall one
segment that Stephen Colbert did where
he made fun of Al Sharpton you when
interviewed al Sharpton it was really
funny it was when al Sharpton was doing
his hunger strike over Guantanamo Bay
and I remember Stephen Colbert kind of
prodding and going it looks like
somebody here could use a hunger strike
this is al Sharpton and his fat days and
it was pretty funny stuff now Stephen
Colbert has just become a Chuck Schumer
at talking points machine he and Jimmy
Kimmel are in the College of Cardinals
of leftist comedy and then they just
have an open competition as to whom will
be elected Pope of left his comedy and
then somewhere in the background is
Jimmy Fallon going guys I want into the
club please and like no it's too late
you ruffled Donald Trump's hair you
can't and so he's been falling in the
ratings because he wasn't woke enough to
begin with well there's only one problem
with that which is that most of the
country is not particularly interested
in Stephen Colbert's brand of comedy he
only has to win a very very small
segment of the audience to win late
night nobody watches late-night anymore
probably nearly as many people watch
this show on a daily basis and watch
Colbert's show maybe more if you count
our radio show but nonetheless will we
get Stephen Colbert's perspective in
just one second first dudes summer is
here Tommy John is ready to have you
looking and feeling ready for Memorial
Day barbecues and fourth of July
fireworks but keep your patriotic this
holiday with their only red white and
blue underwear collection including a
USA flag print for both men and women
the collection comes in all their
best-selling fabrics including the cool
cotton fabric that features breathable
lightweight fibers they keep you two to
three times cooler and dry four to five
times faster than regular cotton both
Tommy John men's and women's underwear
sporting no wedgie guarantee comfortable
stay put waist bands a range of fabrics
that are luxuriously soft designed to
move with you not against you Plus now
through the end of may Tommy John is
donating 5% of every purchase of select
red white and blue styles to the honor
foundation to support veterans
transitioning to civilian life they are
so sure you're gonna love the fit and
feel of Tommy John it's all backed by
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee that means if you don't
love your first pair you get the full
refund Tommy John and no adjustment
needed I know how comfortable Tommy
John's underwear are why because they're
grasing at my took us right now go to
Tommy John calm
Ben right now save 20% on your first
order that's Tommy John comm / Ben first
once he percent off Tommy John comm /
Ben go check them out right now Tommy
John comm / Ben for that special deal
20% off not bad alrighty so Stephen
Colbert does this interview with the New
York Times it is incredibly fawning as
most of these interviews are and here is
what he says he's asked is president
Trump good for comedy how do you come up
with a fresh joke about him and Colbert
says I make no claim that we do
sometimes it's the same joke now this is
normally where you would stop and say
then you're not doing your job right I
mean like you're a comedian when you
have to make different jokes half of
humor is the element of surprise no you
can keep making the same joke about
Trump and your leftist audience will eat
it up Dana it's not even a callback joke
like when I do my Christmas voice it
basically is a callback joke because
it's inherently funny because it's it's
kind of a mediocre impersonation but
it's got sort of the the cadence down
but it's a callback joke mostly like the
half of the funniness is the familiarity
of it that's not the case with the
punchlines that he tells about Trump he
says sometimes there's still meat left
on that chicken Trump consumes the news
cycle in our mandate says Stephen
Colbert as we've established for
ourselves is that I want to inform the
audience of my opinion about what
they've been thinking about all day so
if the news has been orange Thanos then
I'm not going to change that I'm gonna
do my best to stand in the teeth of that
particular bleep hurricane and make
jokes about how we're all being lied to
for my own hearts ease I'm not gonna
pretend the Trump is not lying to me the
alternative is to stick your head in the
sand
oh what a truth teller he is this is the
same guy who spent his years on on The
Colbert Report mocking Bill O'Reilly and
smooching Barack Obama's posterior but
what a truth teller he is now listen I
do appreciate that Stephen Colbert is
basically now just saying look I'm a
leftist I'm gonna make leftist jokes all
right that at least is fair but it is
worth noting that when a lot of these
comedians do the clown nose on clown
nose off routine where it's like well I
make a joke about Trump cuz I'm a
comedian I make jokes about everybody
and then the minute they talk politics
I'm since you I'm sincerely a Democrat
on the Left I'm a sincere sincere person
pick one or pick the other if you're a
Democrat who makes jokes or you're a
joker who happens to be a Democrat but
you can't be both and people like
Stephen Colbert want to pretend they're
both they really are not the New York
Times says that thing about not wanting
to let Trump get away with why is it
fair to say you feel a moral imperative
your work Wow look at those hard-hitting
questions from the New York Times well
when you make jokes about politicians
there's what they say and what they do
it's it's hard to make jokes about
someone who says something and then kind
of does it but with a guy who points
east with his words and West with his
action that's where all the jokes live
now what are the things he's lying about
if the things he's lying about have a
moral component your jokes will have a
moral component in other words you don't
choose the flavor the flavor is chosen
by politics itself and then the New York
Times has a more important question they
say there's a sort of general answer
about the default moral nature of
political satire I was asking more
specifically about whether or not you
personally feel any sense of moral
obligation about your work he says no
okay that's obviously a lie he obviously
does feel a moral sense of obligation he
has just said in his past two answers
that he feels a sense that he has to
speak truth to Orange Thanos or he can't
sleep at night but now he's gonna tell
you about his high-minded comedy is what
I mean by the clown is on clown nose
offered him he says I mean I have
morality
I suppose it's rated to my catholicity
you mean Catholicism this is I was
raised in a devout Catholic home and
bottle-fed Robert bolts a man for all
seasons which is about how it's
important that you not let the tide of
history sweep you along if you don't
actually agree with it and William
Buckley said he stands with word history
yelling stop I think we would the show
standeth wort history and say that's
dumb what a little bleep that is is that
moral I don't know I know that public
lies that you are impelled to believe
are worse than private ones but I'm not
Erin Brokovich I'm sure as hell not
Howard Beale a fair amount of the time
I'm making poop jokes
matter of fact Jon Stewart when it
looked like The Colbert Report come out
of the box fully assembled and was gonna
happen he said to me when your children
go up to get their diplomas
and whatever college they end up going
you going to I want you to whisper to
yourself quietly as they get the
sheepskin I paid for some of this with
poop jokes well again this is the part
that drives people on the right up a
wall up a wall just say what you mean
dude you're a far lefty and you like
making jokes about Trump and you feel a
moral sense that you have to make jokes
about Trump don't tell us it's all about
the poop jokes it isn't about the poop
jokes the poop jokes are a way for you
to make money off of hating President
Trump off of hating Republicans and
conservatives and that's why your poop
jokes don't land most of the time
Colbert has become a less funny human
being since he decided he was a
political partisan the fact is you can
be a political commentator with some
humor I think that's what this show is
or you can be a comedian who does some
politics that's theoretically
Barriss show is but his show is probably
closer to mine now and I haven't changed
my show one iota since the very first
day we started doing it that says
something about why people are not as
interested in late night TV generally at
least on the right
he says for example the New York Times
asked Colbert the other day your
monologue was about the de facto Alabama
abortion ban he said yeah I had avoided
making jokes about it because you just
can't win making jokes about abortion
half of the people are just gonna be mad
at you but Alabama was an unavoidable
one the reason we did it was because
that was about I thought a very cynical
purposeful overreach even the people who
were writing the law said they don't
want that law he's gonna have to cite
some sources on the people who wrote
that law don't want the law I've talked
to the people who wrote the law they
want the law okay so in other words
again he says oh no you know I was in
you're gonna piss off it but Alabama
that's when I had to make my stand pick
a lane pick a lane either if you're
Chris Matthews pick a lane are you a
journalist or are you a democratic hack
if you're Stephen Colbert are you a
comedian or are you a leftist hack which
one it's gonna be and you can say you're
a comedian with left leanings I'm okay
with that but that means occasionally
you're gonna have to tell jokes about
people with whom you agree politically
it's it's it's pretty it's pretty MIT no
wonder people don't trust the media okay
meanwhile President Trump is over in
Britain being greeted by some of the
most mature humour that the that the
great minds over in Britain have to
offer so there's this story that was
pumped up no pun intended by The
Huffington Post about a farmer who gets
a British high school student a cheeky
British high school student carved a
giant penis into his family's spacious
lawns to give Donald Trump a big
resistance hello as the president flew
into London on Monday the penis paired
with the words boy Trump can easily be
seen from the air and it's just minutes
from the London Stansted Airport where
Trump landed the protest art also
included a giant polar bear with the
message climate change is real well I
guess that you know according to the
constitution article 35 Trump is no
longer the president if he sees a giant
penis mowed into a lawn from the air
he's done it's amazing I know you didn't
know about that particular provision of
the Constitution turns out it's true all
I could think of when when I saw
this picture of a high school cartoon
penis labeled Boyd Trump and then Po and
then pushed by The Huffington Post all I
could think of is Trump from there going
I'd sell it uh I mean wait till they see
this thing if it's because you know that
that was Trump's response right I do
love all the people in Britain who think
that they've really gotten under from
skin with this sort of thing and it's
not just that it's also their protests
in in London and not only were there
protests in London the BBC which is the
state-sponsored broadcast network is I
have been made aware it's a
state-sponsored broadcast network of
course I knew this for forever I mean
it's the BBC the British Broadcasting
Corporation and the and the BBC had in
the studio the blimp
of baby Trump which is a staple of
resistance stupidity it's just a blimp
that looks like Trump it isn't all that
big I remember when the when the media
started pushing this they made it sound
like it was the size of the Hindenburg
in fact it's basically you know the size
of like a small bouncy house and the BBC
had it in studio here is what that
looked like touchdown in the UK for his
state visit an hour ago and he kicked
things off with one of his trademark
controversial tweets describing the
Mayor of London as a foolishly nasty and
a stone-cold loser protests are planned
across the UK including in London where
a bigger version of this Trump baby
balloon is you to fly over the capital
and they had it in studio imagine if Fox
News had liked the bull rider mask of
Barack Obama in the studio at Fox what
would the reaction me that's a
state-sponsored news outlet by the way
so when I rip the baby say it's because
the BBC absolutely deserves it as every
conservative in Britain knows with the
exception of people who are paid by the
BBC it's pretty incredible okay we'll
get to more of the British treatment of
President Trump in just a second first
here's an alarming statistic for you
over 75% of Americans are dangerously
deficient in omega-3 levels if you're
experiencing joint pain or chronic
inflammation lack of concentration
weight gain chances are you might be one
of them no matter your age height weight
gender omega-3 fatty acids are vital to
your overall health they're considered a
pill worth taking by the expert
they are clinically proven to improve
mood memory brain cardiovascular health
many of the top sellers simply don't
contain a lot of omega-3 at least not
enough to notice therapeutic results if
you want to feel the benefits instantly
what you should try is a max 3
ultra-pure Oh max they're offering my
listeners 50% off a one month supply of
Oh max 3 plus free shipping and then
60-day money-back guarantee all you have
to do is head on over to Omax health.com
and enter code Shapiro today to take
advantage of this incredible savings
that is OMA ex health com
enter code Shapiro for 50% off a
one-month supply you hear all the hype
around Omega threes well now is your
chance to try the most trusted omega-3
on the market today go - Oh max health
calm enter code Shapiro so who can
benefit from Amex 3 pretty much anybody
just go check them out right now at Oh
max health.com
and enter promo code Shapiro for a
special deal Oh max health.com alrighty
so in just a second we'll get to the
rest of president Trump's quasi
hilarious British visit we'll also be
getting to a debate that is broken out
in conservative circles that I think
it's kind of fascinating and I think is
worthy of explication first you're gonna
have to go and subscribe over at daily
wire comm for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription over at daily wire when
you do you get the rest of this show
live two additional hours of the show
every day as I've said before that
basically means that you're getting the
show all day long because we do this
show in the morning and then we have
another show in the afternoon so
whatever breaks in between we cover and
then we come back and do it again the
next day this is why you should
subscribe also for $99 a year you get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist cheers hot or cold
tumbler so you can enjoy those leftist
years both hot and cold well listening
to me do a Christmas impersonation that
sounds like the height of life enjoyment
to me but then again I'm the one doing
it so I hope you enjoyed it so go check
that out right now with the annual
subscription Isle so when you get the
annual subscription you get access to
the Sunday special on Saturdays we have
a great Sunday special coming up this
Sunday we have some fantastic ones that
are coming up in the real near future
but some people across the other side of
the aisle which makes them really
interesting we're gonna do all that sort
of stuff we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so Jeremy Corbyn who is a
terrorist mouthpiece he says that
President Trump the Trump London protest
is a chance to stand in solidarity he's
the leader of the British Labour Party
and a radical anti-semite and he joined
a protest against Donald Trump because
nothing says good relations quite like
protesting a guy you may have to deal
with if you become Prime Minister of the
UK it's just a genius political move he
tweeted out tomorrow's protest against
Donald Trump's state visit is an
opportunity to stand in solidarity with
those he's attacked in America around
the world and in our own country
including just this morning Sadiq Khan
Sadiq Khan of course is considered a
victim because Sadiq Khan is what was
was ripped on by President Trump now the
reason that President Trump ripped on
him is because on Saturday Sadiq Khan
wrote a long editorial for the Guardian
which is the far-left newspaper in
Britain called its unbrushed
to roll out the red carpet for Donald
Trump now there's something rich about
Sadiq Khan talking about it being
unbrushed
to be nice to the American president the
fact is that the dude has some pretty
shady connections according to the Daily
Mail is back in 2016 before Sadiq Khan
was elected to the mayoralty of London
Sadiq Khan who is a local Labour MP
he was at a funeral in 2016 one figure
whose hand he stopped to shake stood out
convicted terrorist Baba Rahman a man
who had been blamed for inspiring a
generation of extremists including the
gang behind the London bombings of July
7th 2005 the pair exchanged brief
pleasantries before Khan move on the
encounter took place a few months ago
around the time of Khan's nomination as
Labour's mayoral candidate since then
riding on the crest of jeremy corbyn's
left his takeover of the Labour Party
Khan has left conservative mayoral
candidate Zac Goldsmith trailing in his
wake new revelations this weekend about
Hakan shared a platform with yasser el
Surrey a convicted terrorist and
associate of hate preacher Abu Qatada
and Sahil Shaheed a militants who helped
to train the ringleader of London
bombings are the most serious
allegations so far said he Khan's
interactions with controversial
characters all are not all in the past
furthermore it transpires that the MP
for Tooting is a divisive character in
his South London community with dark
allegations of threats and betrayal in
his own political backgrounds the city
Khan has a long history of some pretty
nasty connections
and not just that his policies in London
have been a complete abysmal disaster
knife crime in London has been up
dramatically under Sadiq Khan there's
tremendous cultural strain inside of
London largely because Sadiq Khan is not
a unifying figure he's a very polarizing
figure so he got into a fight with
President Trump and so Jeremy Corbyn is
of course backing him because Corbin
backs him for Mayor of London in the
first place
Trump arrives in the UK Monday morning
for a three-day visit Trump not only
Montcalm but he came out just today and
he said that Jeremy Corbyn wanted to
meet with him and that Trump turned him
down so whether that is true or not as
anybody's guess Trump has said this
about a bevy of politicians many of whom
it's not true about right from there
very often when somebody rejects Trump
he goes I rejected you first boom take
that with that said Jeremy Corbyn is a
bad human and the fact that he is
protesting from is demonstrative of just
where he stands on a lot of these issues
now the good news is that Queen
Elizabeth is still being nice to Trump
as she should
she is the ceremonial head of state in
Britain so here she is praising
president Trump and saying you have a
connection to this country here look the
reason that Trump is over there is
because it's the 75th anniversary of
d-day I mean we just did a Sunday
special about the 75th anniversary of
d-day in which the United States sent a
million people to stay over in Britain
and then help liberate the European
continent from Nazi from Nazi evil so
the President of the United States
visiting for that that doesn't seem like
it should be wildly controversial
nonetheless it is because everything is
stupid and controversial now here is
Queen Elizabeth talking to President
Trump as we face the new challenges of
the 21st century the anniversary of
d-day reminds us all that our countries
have achieved together of course it is
not only our security which unites us
but our strong cultural links and shared
heritage every year there are almost 4
million visits by Americans to the
United Kingdom with a great number
claiming British descent and with your
own Scottish ancestry mr. president you
too have a particular connection to this
country
okay so all of this is nice and
wonderful in all of it is being treated
with scorn and mockery by the mainstream
media who are too busy tweeting out
pictures of president Trump's to belong
vest this is really what they spent the
day doing yesterday there's a picture of
President Trump and he is wearing his
tuxedo vest and just like his ties he
wears his tuxedo vest soo and so it
drops at least a full four feet below
his actual dinner jacket this apparently
is a major scandal over in Britain the
same media that said that it was no big
deal
when Michelle Obama touched the person
is of the Queen we're going crazy
because apparently Trump touched the
personage of the Queen listen I'm very
glad we don't have royalty in this
country I really am because those sorts
of rules are so dumb I'm sorry like what
what's he gonna do burst into flame it's
not for religious reasons of modesty and
she's just the Royal person in any case
whenever Barack Obama traveled to broad
he was stories from the media about the
triumphant a triumphant mood of
President Obama abroad whenever Trump
travels abroad it's always about the
protests the reality is the protests
were smaller than expected in London
because no one really cares and he was
treated the way that he should have been
treated by the vast majority of people
in positions of power in London those
will not be the headlines that you are
reading tonight okay meanwhile there's
been this fascinating debate that I've
been waiting to to sort of comment on
until everybody had their opinions out
there
listen bate was kicked off by a guy
named Saurabh Amari who I am friends
with I'm friends with friendly with
Saurabh Amari he is a the editor of the
New York Post op-ed page and he's
written a really good book that I've
recommended on the show about his
conversion to Catholicism he wrote a
piece basically ripping on David French
a person who I'm also friends with and
who has been against multiple times on
the show I thought that the piece was
misdirected against French but basically
Saurabh Amari
was criticizing the libertarian
instincts of a lot of Republicans what
he was saying is that government needs
to be involved in certain ways in order
to promote virtue and family formation
whereas David French people like me we
have suggested that a smaller government
is the best answer and that culture
cannot be built by the government
culture precedes government and so what
you really need to do if you want to
have a better virtuous culture what you
really need to do is change hearts and
minds and you need a government that is
unable to fight those sorts of cultural
movements from
below so the role of government is
really the question here
Ross doo-dads a very thoughtful
columnist over at the New York Times and
he has a piece about this today and I
think that it's worthy of note because
it does go to something that's been
roiling the conservative movement for a
little while he says basically the best
way to understand the sorbonne re-tape
in french split is in light of the old
fusion the old consensus that the first
things manifest to attach so first
things as a catholic magazine and they
wrote a piece a while back called
against I believe it was called against
the dead consensus and they were
apparently ripping on the the kind of
Reagan coalition the idea that social
conservatism government libertarianism
small government that this could coexist
basically was an argument sort of in
Tucker Carlson mode that government
needs to be more involved in promoting
virtue so here's what dude hat writes he
says French is a religious conservative
who thinks that the pre Trump
conservative vision still make sense he
thinks his Christian faith and his
pro-life convictions have a natural home
in a basically libertarian coalition one
that wants to limit the federal
government's interventions in the
marketplace and expects civil society to
flourish once state powered is removed
he thinks that believers and
non-believers secular liberals and
conservatives can coexist under a
classical liberal framework in which
disputes are settled by persuasion
rather than constant legal skirmishing
or else are left unsettled in a healthy
pluralism Amaury on the other hand
speaks for the cultural conservatives
who believe that the old conservative
fusion mostly failed they're part of the
movement winning victories for tax
cutters and business interests while
marriage rates decline birth rates
plummeted and religious affiliation wane
when appeasing social conservatives with
judges who never actually got around to
overturning Roe vs. Wade
these conservatives believe that the
current version of social liberalism has
no interest in truces or pluralism and
won't rest till the last evangelical
Baker is find into bankruptcy
the last Catholic hospital or adoption
agency is closed by an ACLU lawsuit they
think the business interests have turned
into agents of cultural revolution
making them poor allies for the right
and that the free trade and
globalization championed by past
Republican presidents has played some
role in the dissolution of conservatism
substrates the family the neighborhood
the local Civitas when they've warm
quickly or slowly to the politics is war
style of the current president but what
specifically do these conservatives want
besides a sense of thrill and calm
that David French's style denies them
and that really is the big question
because I agree with both of these
characterizations right I actually group
both Amari and French so I agree with
David French that a small government is
the best solution because I believe that
government is the ring of power if you
think that you can control the ring of
power and then use that ring of power
for your own side it is only a matter of
time before it falls into the hands of
the other side and is used against you I
think there are two dueling narratives
here
dueling there - a narrative number one
is sort of the libertarian narrative and
that is here's what happened in the
United States here's my social liberal
liberalism has conquered all basically
government got larger and government got
larger in order to perform functions
that a lot of conservatives were sort of
on board with and then government
continued to grow larger and larger
people began to rely on government more
than they relied on their local
community more than they relied on that
Civitas and then as government grew
larger the country grew more liberal so
there's a straight-line correlation
between the growth of government and the
growth of leftism
and now that huge massive burdensome
government is going to be used by the
left to cram down its values on the rest
of us that's the that's the version I
believe then there is the version that
is being promoted by some of the first
things and their version goes something
like this
government grew big and it grew big for
some good reasons and some bad reasons
and then because government grew big
there was a counter response that was
libertarian in nature conservatism
became libertarian and wanted less
government along with that libertarian
move came a surrender first reaction in
conservatism to social conservative
issues so the idea would be that in
order to fight the growth of government
conservatism decided to abandon
government's role in promoting public
virtue and that's what led to the
hollowing out of civic institutions and
so we really need to do is grab
government back and then use it to
promote those social institutions again
I agree with version number one I don't
think that William F Buckley was
stumping against social conservatism I
basically saying I think that
conservatives for decades have basically
been saying that the business of civic
virtue is something that is supposed to
be inculcated by a strong social network
understanding the history of
judeo-christian values in our society I
just wrote an entire book about this but
that you can't impose that from above
because if you do impose that from above
number one it's not going to
work number two it doesn't allow for the
pluralistic vision of a society that the
founding was supposed to create hey how
do you determine when the government has
gone too far
and its imposition of morality for
example wouldn't be better to leave this
to the local level and if you disagree
with the local government you can leave
wouldn't it be better to leave this to
informal mechanisms in society why are
we seeing governments as the great
promoter of religion or of
judeo-christian values when that really
should be done in the churches and the
real key should be preventing government
from encroaching into those spaces now
listen I understand the temptation I
understand the temptation for a lot of
conservatives which is those spaces are
not going to exist if the left gets its
way the question is can you retain those
spaces by grabbing the government back
what are the prospects of grabbing
government back and using it to cram
down values that you believe and protect
the values you believe and what are the
prospects of simply destroying the
government power altogether I am much
more in favor of throwing the ring into
the fire because I think that that sword
can be and has been used historically by
the left
perfect example same-sex marriage so I
used to be in favor of governmental
enshrined traditional marriage and then
I became in my twenty eleven twenty
twelve before Barack Obama I believe I
started talking about how conservatives
should be libertarian why the reason was
not because I believe that same-sex
marriage is moral as a religious person
I not only believe that it's sinful but
on a natural law level I don't think
same-sex marriage provides the same
benefits to society as traditional
marriage obviously hit but I said that
the best solution for conservatives was
to remove this power from government
altogether because sooner or later the
government was going to move to the left
and then they would be cramming down
their values on your churches and that's
exactly what has happened so the
question is what's the best way to
promote conservative values from the
bottom up with a social network
promoting a social network in the
absence of government encroachment or
from the top-down by keeping a strong
government trying to capture that
regulatory power on behalf of the values
that you like this is the battle that is
happening right now I think it's an open
battle I think it's an honest battle I
think it's a worthwhile battle but I do
think that it is worthwhile for
libertarians to consider on a serious
level what sort of social networks are
necessary to fill in that gap and I
think it's necessary for social
conservatives who may want to control
things
at a governmental level to consider what
happens if you lose and you've now built
the Machine of your own destruction
because you built it to protect you but
now it can be turned against you that's
that's really the question going forward
for conservatives okay time for some
things that I like and then some things
that I don't
so things that I like today so as you
know I am a huge baseball fan I've read
virtually all the baseball books there's
a good new book called power ball by
Robb Mayer
it really is pretty great here's the I
believe he used to write for Sports
Illustrated and ESPN if I'm not mistaken
in any case Mayer's book basically takes
a meaningless late season game between
the Oakland Athletics and the and the
Houston Astros and Bret sit down out by
out and it sort of had these these
cutaways to various discussions of
issues in the game baseball ranging from
whether the ball has changed spoiler
alert yes the ball has changed that's
why you're getting more home runs to the
pace of play it's it's really great it's
kind of like listening to a really great
broadcaster watching an actual baseball
game the key to a really great
broadcaster when you watch a baseball
game is that during the periods of dead
space when things aren't really
happening on a field can they give you
more information and more stuff that you
want to know and that sort of a Rob NER
does here the book is definitely worth
reading now he does have the obligatory
sjw stuff he has I think three separate
sections on whether there is a gay
baseball player I don't understand why
anybody cares about that like really it
doesn't matter to me if a player is gay
I don't think it matters to pretty much
anyone at this point whether a player is
gay but Rob Neyer suggests that it's
still massive homophobia inside the MLB
this sort of stuff if you can get past
that sort of stuff then the baseball
portion of this is really good my one
critique the editor should have removed
some of the exclamation points he writes
with a lot of exclamation points and
those should have been toned down but
that is an editorial critique the book
itself is is very enjoyable okay let's
do some things that I hate
okay so the the fact that the left will
embrace anybody who just says bad things
about Trump is pretty astonishing
Charles blow the aptly named Charles
blow over at the New York Times is a
terrible columnist he has a piece called
the princess versus the demagogue Wow
it's me like a fairy tale he says in an
interview Saturday with Rupert Murdoch's
right-wing British tabloid the son
president Trump characterized statements
by Megan Marco before she became the
Duchess of Sussex as nasty during the
2016 campaign of course Trump was being
led in this exchange to be precisely who
we all know he is the question itself
was problematic as it disclosed a biased
characterization by the journalist who
asks Trump are you sorry not to see her
because she wasn't so nice about you
during the campaign I don't know if you
saw that I love Charles blow calling out
media bias that's pretty pretty the guy
works for the New York Times says nice
that's right in answer him to nasty it
was a setup but one that both parties
wanted the son is in some ways like a
British print edition of America's Fox
News it but it is also Britain's largest
paper that's the paradox that's not a
paradox a paradox is like if an object
is large and also a small it is not a
paradox to say a conservative newspaper
has a lot of subscribers in the UK that
this is why I say not a good columnist
he says indeed shortly after the 2015
Paris terrorist attacks the son
published an ominous headline they cover
nearly all of the front page in a large
font and large white fonts on a black
background the paper asserted one in
five Brit Muslims sympathy for jihadis
as the independent reported the headline
was accompanied by an image of British
British Isis member mohammed emwazi also
known as jihadi John who is hoisting a
knife there's a reference to a piece
entitled time for Britain to shut door
the paper was ordered to admit that the
story was significantly misleading but
you can understand why Trump would be
amenable to it how does he get to this
from Trump saying that he is that he
thought that megyn Markel was nasty here
it says it was simply wrong to
characterize Merkel's comments as nasty
they were simply factual she said in a
2016 interview on the nightly show with
Larry Wilmore that Trump was divisive
and misogynistic and vocal about it
where's the Y oh my god they really so
you're gonna rip on Trump for saying
that she was nasty to him after she
called him divisive misogynistic and and
vocal about it okay like really you may
agree with her characterization but it
is nice right I mean
I assume that half the stuff I said
about 2016 President Trump wouldn't like
he's fully entitled not to like things a
better journalist says Charles blow if
he or she wanted to have Trump weigh in
on the comments would simply read Marcos
response and asked for the president's
response but they didn't and Trump went
directly to the place he feels most
comfortable referring to women who
opposed him as nasty
I have no royalist fetish irreverence as
Charles Bo indeed I find the existence
of royalty in any society problematic
but this isn't as much about Trump's
reaction to a princess a princess as it
is about his reaction 12th woman in this
case a black woman yeah
really seriously this is what we're
gonna do
Trump has called a bevy of women nasty
he said it about Hillary Clinton I
believe at one point he said it about
megyn kelly he said it about I believe
stormy Daniels are any of those women
black he has said that men are nasty to
him so now the president uses the word
nasty and it's about race and sex you
wonder why people are getting pretty
irritated with the use of the racist
sexist label this would be the reason
this would be the reason right here and
then it's just Charles blow quoting all
the old stuff about Trump being mean to
women yes
Trump is bad with women he's been bad
with women his entire career do you have
anything new to present her Charles blow
or do you just wish to rail against
President Trump calling Megan Marco
nasty that one does not even rank in the
top hundred comments from his made about
women by the way not the top hundred
public comments charles beau concludes
society itself offers a graduate level
course in misogyny and every exam is a
take-home test what what the hell does
that even mean oh god do the editors at
the New York Times have nothing to do
all day that doesn't even mean anything
every exam is a take-home test what the
real work comes in consciously combating
our bias and attempting to deprogram
ourselves from blindly accepting
privileges and ignoring oppressions or
here's the thing
Trump is absolutely a misogynist his
main note
well sorry and when I hear a column of
heated 100 times in row by the same
columnist I start to lose interest so
sorry Charles blow I couldn't finish
that one up for you my bad
seems like you as a columnist couldn't
finish it up either but you know it's my
job to read it I guess okay final piece
of news today there's a new CNN poll you
want to talk about media bias this is
pretty great so Ryan's truck is a is a
statistics analyst for CNN he put out a
new CNN poll today here is the poll by
than 32 Sanders 18 Harris 8 Warren 7 boo
to judge 500 Roark 5 Booker 3 Castro 2
and then I always look for Kristen
Gillibrand just cuz it's hilarious
kirsten gillibrand one which is always
humorous to me here is the best part
Ryan struck Tweetup Biden's support
stands at 32% down slightly from 39% in
April how is 32% down slightly from 39%
like just just a question if any other
cans in it lost 7% wouldn't be a pretty
major move moving from doubling up
Bernie Sanders to losing 7 points that
is now dispersed among the crowd isn't
that a sign that maybe burn and maybe
Joe Biden's high point has come and gone
then maybe Joe Biden is is gonna start
collapsing in on himself I mean wouldn't
that be like a more interesting at least
analysis how's the seven-point drop a
minor drop that is Elizabeth Warren's
entire support base she's at 7% right
now it's run from 7 to 0 would that be
insignificant you know Joe Biden man a
lot of members of the media rooting for
him because they think he's gonna be
Trump but um you know these stats are
showing the Joe Biden's got some
vulnerability he may have hit his high
point already all right will we be we
will be back here later this afternoon
with two additional hours of programming
we will see you then i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know the
knuckleheads on knucklehead row that's
the op-ed page in The New York Times are
predicting the end of the Republican
Party why they think we can handle
diversity
guess what knuckleheads we don't give a
crap about diversity we don't care what
color you are as long as you're colored
American we'll talk about that and
Trump's trip to the UK on the Andrew
Clavin show